veamos si podemos extender el problema
de contar caminos del video pasado a
tres
dimensiones Así es que digamos que
tenemos un cubo de 3 por TR lo vamos a
mantener en 3 por TR para que no sea
demasiado complicado lo das cuentas y
todo eso Bueno creo que debía haber
usado la herramienta de líneas derechas
pero bueno ni modo a ver tenemos este
cubo Esta es la parte de enfrente del
cubo y el cubo se va hacia atrás y hacia
abajo y hace enfrente es un cubo de 3x
TR como un cubo de
Rubik lo pude haber dibujado mejor pero
creo que será lo suficiente para
nosotros muy bien Ahí está un cubo de 3
por
TR entonces lo que nosotros queremos
hacer es llegar desde la esquina de
arriba a la izquierda al fondo esta
esquina hasta esta otra esquina de
enfrente a la derecha y hasta abajo esta
esquina Esta es nuestra meta y solo nos
podemos mover en tres direcciones desde
cualquier cubo nos podemos mover hacia
enfrente en esta
dirección Ajá nos podemos mover hacia
abajo en esta otra dirección o nos
podemos mover hacia la derecha no lo
puedo dibujar ah no sí lo puedo dibujar
miren ahí lo estoy dibujando Entonces al
igual que en el video pasado
solo nos podemos acercar a la meta no
podemos sí podemos mover hacia abajo y
luego a la derecha pero luego no nos
podemos mover hacia arriba Entonces cada
paso nos va a acercar un poco más a la
meta Los Caminos van desde la esquina de
arriba atrás a la izquierda hasta la
esquina de abajo adelante a la derecha
entonces Cuántas formas hay de llegar de
su esquina a esa esquina Cuántos caminos
hay entre ellos le puedes poner pausa y
tratar de resolverlo yo estoy a punto de
empezar a resolverlo aquí lo primero que
uno hace es tratar de visualizar este
cubo pero pues o sea visualizar los
cubos de medio y todos los caminos que
hay en medio no es tan sencillo la forma
más fácil de hacerlo es empezar a
visualizar capa por capa empecemos por
esta capa de aquí la capa le vamos a
llamar la capa magenta Esta es la capa
magenta
aquí y van a ver lo que estoy haciendo
en un segundo esta
Es la capa no sé Lila Okay esta capa de
en medio es la capa Lila le podemos
llamar nivel también y finalmente el
nivel de hasta abajo es el nivel
naranja
Okay lo que podemos hacer es dibujar
cada uno de estos niveles por separado
primero hay que dibujar el nivel
magenta a ver bueno no eso no es lo que
yo quería hacer a ver Esta es la capa
magenta el nivel
magenta vamos a dibujarle unos
cuadrados aquí y
así y de esta forma y así Okay ahora
vamos con el nivel Lila Okay este es el
nivel
Lila
Ajá ahora o sea se pueden imaginar que
me estoy que estoy rebanando el cubo no
y estas son
vistas desde
arriba Okay est es la rebanada
Lila y ahora vamos con la rebanada
naranja el nivel naranja
aj con sus
cuadrados Okay ya estamos casi listos
para empezar a resolver el
problema bien ahora para ver que s lo
entendimos En serio bueno para reforzar
esto Esta es el nivel uno
Ajá esta capa este nivel es el nivel
dos le estoy poniendo numeritos
chiquitos para que no se confundan con
la cantidad de caminos que hay en cada
cubo Este es el nivel tres Ajá y Bueno
okay esta esquina el el punto donde
empezamos es este mismo
y Esta es toda la rebanada de arriba
okay Y nuestra meta es justo este
cuadrado este
cubo entonces esencialmente nuestro
problema es Cuántas formas hay de llegar
de aquí acá Cuántos caminos hay entonces
quedémonos en la rebanada de arriba
Cuántas formas hay de llegar aquí pues
solo podemos ir desde el punto de inicio
directamente hasta acá no entonces hay
una única forma ese movimiento es justo
este de acá Okay ir del esta caja esta
caja es un movimiento un camino podemos
tomar otro paso y llegar acá es justo ir
aquí y aquí de la misma forma podemos
tomar un paso a la derecha y llegar aquí
tomar dos pasos a la derecha y llegar
acá Esos son los únicos caminos que hay
de llegar a esos cuadrados si vieron el
video anterior ya sabrán perfectamente
que hay dos caminos para llegar acá dos
formas Y pues lo podemos dibujar no o
sea puede ser un camino Dos caminos que
es lo mismo que dibujar acá este camino
o este camino es más fácil de ver aquí
pero bueno la forma de verlo era bueno
para saber cuántas formas hay de llegar
a este cuadrado pues pensamos qué
cuadrados llegan a ese cuadrado y
cuántos caminos hay de llegar a esos
cuadrados y sumarlo entonces hay Tres
formas de llegar ahí 2 + 1 son 3 1 + 2
son 3 y luego 3 + 3 son 6 entonces hay
seis formas de llegar aquí desde el
inicio Esto no es muy diferente del
video anterior ior pero ahorita va a
empezar la parte interesante Cuántas
formas hay debía haber cambiado el color
Pero bueno cuántas formas hay de llegar
a ese cuadrado que es justo este que
estamos coloreando aquí pues empezamos
aquí y solo puedo ir hacia abajo no hay
una única forma de empezar y una única
forma de ir hacia abajo que es una forma
de aquí y lo podemos extender como hay
una única forma de ir ahí yendo hacia
abajo también podemos ir otra vez hacia
abajo y hay una única forma de ir dos
veces hacia abajo entonces hay una única
forma de llegar ahí Espero que lo
entiendan no O sea esta es la parte de
abajo Ajá empezamos aquí nos vamos hacia
abajo acá y luego otra vez hacia abajo
acá bien Ahora aquí es donde se pone
interesante Cuántas formas hay de llegar
a este
cubo Pues en nuestro ejemplo viejo solo
había una forma no yendo desde la
izquierda ahora podemos ir desde la
izquierda y podemos venir desde arriba
este es yendo desde arriba Entonces
añadimos este más este entonces 1 + un
son
dos Cuántas formas hay de llegar aquí ni
siquiera podemos ver ese cubo está en el
fondo a la mitad Cuántas formas hay de
llegar aquí hay dos formas desde la
izquierda y hay una forma desde aquí de
arriba Entonces hay 2 + 1 Tres formas
Cuántas formas llegar aquí una desde
atrás y una desde arriba o sea son dos
formas Y cuántas formas de llegar aquí
hay dos desde atrás y Ajá dos formas de
ir de aquí acá y una forma de llegar
desde arriba que es aquí ha arriba Ajá
entonces
ahí bueno este este es dos Ajá y estamos
viendo esta celda entonces hay dos
formas desde la izquierda y hay una
forma desde arriba o sea hay Tres
formas bien Cuántas formas hay de llegar
aquí hay dos tres desde la izquierda
desde atrás o desde arriba Ah entonces
hay 2 + 2 + 2 que son
seis de la misma forma seis desde la
izquierda tres desde atrás y otras tres
desde arriba Entonces hay 12
formas sucede lo mismo en este cubo nu9
desde el nivel morado 6 + 3 9 y desde
arriba otras tres o sea 12 formas y
finalmente Cuántas formas hay de llegar
aquí Ajá pues podemos venir desde la
izquierda que hay 12 formas 12 formas
desde atrás y luego seis formas desde
arriba Okay entonces son 12 + 12 + 6 30
bien ya ven el patrón a ver aquí Cuántas
formas hay de llegar hay 1 + 2 3 Cuántas
fos llegar aquí tres más 3 que son 6 y
aquí uno desde atrás y dos desde arriba
o sea tres y para acá pues tres desde
atrás y tres desde arriba que son se
aquí son 3 + 3 que son 6 más desde
arriba que son otros seis entonces hay
12 Cuántas formas de llegar aquí 12 + 6
18 y hay 12 formas de llegar desde
arriba o sea que hay 18 + 12
de la misma forma hay 18 formas desde el
nivel naranja y 12 formas desde arriba
Entonces hay 30 formas entonces Cuántas
formas hay de llegar a la meta Pues hay
30 formas desde la izquierda 30 formas
desde atrás lo cual son 60 y luego hay
otras 30 formas de llegar desde arriba
Entonces hay 90 formas Okay hay 90
caminos desde una esquina a la otra
desde esta esquina hasta esta esquina 90
caminos bueno en el video pasado hicimos
una
analogía con lo que todo lo que vimos
con el teorema del Binomio Entonces
ahora te voy a dejar de tarea que hagas
la analogía correspondiente pero en tres
dimensiones trata de formular una
especie de teorema del trinomio que te
ayude a multiplicar cosas de la forma x
+ y + z a la enésima potencia puedes
pensar en este en una extensión de este
cubo no en lugar de pensar en un cubo de
3 * 3 por 3 puedes pensar en un cubo de
n * n por n no que te ayude a ver estas
potencias enésimas de x + y + z a mí me
pareció muy un ejercicio muy interesante
de visualización que en realidad no es
más complicado que el del video anterior
Pero bueno antes de terminar quiero
dejarles con un principio general que es
muy útil en pruebas estandarizadas o
juegos de lógica si quiero llegar a ese
vértice Y di digamos que ups no no
quería hacer eso si tenemos un montón de
vértices por ahí Ajá que tien que tener
dirección no me voy a meter en toda la
teoría de gráficas Bueno pero tien que
tener dirección y no puedes tener ciclos
Porque entonces tendrías una infinidad
de formas de llegar a cada punto digamos
que hay x formas de llegar ahí y formas
Z formas y a formas llegar a esos
vértices bien Esto es además un
subconjunto de la Gráfica completa no O
sea también hay otras aristas y
conexiones por ahí que en realidad no
nos interesan estos los cuatro
circulitos verdes son todos los vértices
que llegan al vértice que nos interesa
entonces Cómo podemos llegar ahí pues
podemos llegar desde esos cuatro
vértices verdes Entonces si hay x formas
de llegar desde ese vértice Z formas de
llegar desde ese vértice y a formas de
llegar desde ese vértice en total hay X
+ Y má Z más a formas de llegar y este
tipo de problemas se los van a encontrar
en todos lados Incluso si planean ser
abogados por ejemplo podrían
encontrárselo en los exámenes ala Bueno
espero que lo hayan
disfrutado